we're joined Now by Lisa nandy the
Shadows Secretary of State for leveling
up housing and communities thank you
very much for being with us
um I just want to start with the report
by the dcms committee they say the
Richard chart made significant areas of
judgment in failing to declare his
involvement in facilitating a loan to
Boris Johnson who of course gave him
that job a few weeks later what's your
reaction to the report
it's a really serious development and it
makes Richard Sharp's position
increasingly untenable the government
has relied on the defense that the dcms
the culture media and Sports Select
Committee approve this appointment but
the culture media and support committee
today is saying that actually had they
known about this it would have been a
very different situation this
information was not disclosed to them
prior to approving that appointment
increasingly the circumstances around
the relationship between the
conservative prime minister Boris
Johnson and Richard Sharp is looking in
more and more murky and I think his
position is becoming increasingly
untenable as a result you say his
position is increasingly untenable we
spoke to Andrew Mitchell earlier who
said that effectively this is a matter
for the BBC although the public
appointments commissioner is also
looking into it is that right
I I think this is a something that has
far a wider reaching implications across
um Society because the BBC is a National
Treasure it's a part of our culture it
is something that is supported by people
lots of people across this country
paying money into the license fee that's
a system that we absolutely support but
it means that rightly and understandably
the BBC has helped to very high
standards and when you have the BBC
being pulled into an increasingly murky
situation and ongoing
um reports of conservative sleaze and
corruption that's a very serious thing
indeed and I think it's becoming more
and more difficult to see how Richard
Sharp can continue in that role so you
saying he should resign is that what
you're saying
well there is there is there is a report
that is due from the BBC they're
reviewing this matter at the moment I
think it's right that we give the BBC
time to investigate this and to report
on it but I think today's developments
are incredibly serious and for for
several weeks now the government has
been saying that Parliament had approved
this position well Parliament is now
saying through the culture media and
Sports Select Committee that had they
known about this relationship it would
have been a very different matter and
when that report is published I think we
need to know whether you know there is
any defense of that the reasons for
withholding that information from
Parliament and therefore from the public
and if there isn't a defense I think
it's difficult to see how Richard Sharp
could possibly continue in the position
that he's in given the far-reaching
implications for the reputation of the
BBC and the implications for uh trust in
government and Trust in journalism
now you have used the word murky so I do
just want to put richer sharp statement
across at this point because he's said
that he regrets and apologizes for not
giving the full information to the
committee but he does say that he
believes that he acted in good faith and
that he proactively briefed the cabinet
secretary the other point that I want to
make is that you know some people might
be listening to this thinking look you
only got a problem with this if it's
conservative supporters or conservative
donors who are in positions of power at
the BBC you know whether it's James
Pannell Gavin Davis Greg Dyke they all
had affiliations with labor and jobs at
the BBC so is it just the politics that
you don't like here
I don't think there was ever a
suggestion that James Pennell
um or any of the other names that you
mentioned facilitated personal loans for
the Prime Minister while the appointment
process was ongoing and then withheld
that information from Parliament at a
pre-scrutiny committee session that was
designed exactly to unearth these sorts
of relationships I don't accept that
that accusation at all I think that the
impartiality and integrity of the BBC
matters I'm a strong supporter and
always have been of the BBC and the fact
that it's publicly funded through the
license fee I think it's one of the
great strengths that Britain has not
least because I just heard your
interview with Andrew Mitchell you're
talking about the increasingly unstable
situation across the world increasingly
aggressive behavior by China the BBC
World Service and other news outlets is
a light on the hill for people all over
the world precisely because it is paid
for and funded by millions of people
across this country and its Integrity
matters and that's why this matters so
much not because it's a conservative
appointment not because it's
um now mad in allegations of
conservative sleeves but because it's
being pulled into what is a very
untenable position around this
government and that's not acceptable
Andrew Mitchell said that we should look
at whether lessons could be learned from
this do you think in the future it would
be helpful if for example people who'd
made donations to political parties were
banned from public appointments such as
this
well I mean there's a huge uh you know
much bigger debate around donations to
political parties for my part I
represent a party that is funded by
um millions of people across this
country who put their hands into their
pockets every week and pay small sums in
order to fund us I'm very proud to do
that I think it's the cleanest money in
British politics and I actually think
the answer to this is not
um about the funding of political
parties I think the answer to this is
that those of us in public life have to
behave with integrity and decency and if
we don't not only ought there to be
robust
standards that are upheld and we ought
not to be able to continue in public
life but also that we ought to face the
electorate at The Ballot Box so that
they can make a judgment we've had five
years
um well four years now of this
conservative government mad in
accusations ongoing accusations of
cronyism and sleaze some of which have
been proven and I can't wait for the
general election because I think that
this is really degrading every part of
our political system our journalism
trust in our institutions and I think
profoundly this needs to change okay
um just wanted to point out again from
Richard Sharp's statement he says that
he didn't facilitate an introduction
between Boris Johnson and Mr Blythe and
he wasn't involved in the arrangement of
the loan I'm really Keen to talk as well
about the other story that we've been
covering a lot on Sky News which is the
devastating earthquake in turkey and
Syria I mean it honestly it's just
mind-boggling isn't it what we are
seeing unfolding before our eyes now we
know that Syria in particular of course
has been particularly badly hit because
of the devastation that that country was
already facing UK Aid to Syria halved
between 2020 and 2021 if labor wins the
next election will you immediately
restore the the UK Aid budget to 0.7 of
GDP
we can't make commitments to immediately
start funding
our priorities in government the reason
that we can't do that is because we're
likely to inherit the worst economic
situation since the second world war
because of a decade of touring
mismanagement of the economy I'm
standing here today in Nottingham where
local government leaders are gathering
from across the country that's one of
the messages that I'll be giving to them
today and actually they know it because
right across the country we've seen cut
after cut after cut a consequence of the
fact that we've got low or no growth in
this country our priority is going to be
to get the economy growing by
transferring power out of Westminster
and Whitehall two local leaders and
Business Leaders in our community so
they can start making our economy work
again and as soon as it's practically
possible we will restore the 0.7
commitment we we believe that that is
absolutely essential not just to helping
with the appalling situation in Syria
and in turkey that we're seeing
unfolding on our screens but also to
safeguarding Britain's interests it's
not in Britain's interests to retreat
from the world we used to lead the world
over the last 10 years we've started to
leave it that will reverse under a labor
government but we when we make promises
your viewers should know that we will be
sure that we can keep them
so you want to restore the path to 0.7
as soon as possible I mean it's
basically the same position as the
conservatives then isn't it
well I mean I don't think frankly that
the conservatives have any intention of
doing so Boris Johnson abolished well
they've said that they will they've said
that they will store it when fiscal
circumstances allow which is exactly the
same position as labor
well and credit to Andrew Mitchell who
is just on your program because it was
thanks in part to the uh noise that was
created by Him and other conservative
backbenchers as well as the labor party
that the government felt compelled to
make that commitment but they had to be
dragged Kicking and Screaming to do it
the difference between us and them is
that we believe that by going out and
playing a leading role in the world in
looking to the world beyond our Shores
we helped to safeguard Britain's
interests it's why we've said to the
government that they've been far too
complacent about the rise of China
they've been far too unfocused about
growing Russian aggression on our
doorstep and it's why just a moment ago
you had Andrew Mitchell a ministering
government saying that the government is
now having to revise their 10-year
strategy for how we relate to the rest
of the world only a year after they
published it I'm glad that they're doing
it but every single time this government
has to be drug Kicking and Screaming to
recognize that what happened beyond our
Shores matters deeply to the interests
of the British people our record in
government shows otherwise and when
we're in government again we will help
to safeguard Britain's interests by
reaching out to the world and leading
not leaving
just finally you are talking about
transferring power away from Westminster
to local communities this weekend I
guess my real question is you know
if you've had dealings with your local
councils I'm sure lots of people
watching this program will have why on
Earth would you think that local
authorities are any better at dealing
with these issues than Westminster
well because if you look at the example
from across the country whether it's in
Telford where the labor Council has gone
out and secured millions of pounds worth
of investment to create jobs and to
skill up their young people to be able
to get those jobs whether it's Tracy
braben the mayor of West Yorkshire who
has recently support secured a thousand
jobs for Bradford by flying across the
world and explaining the benefits of
investing in her region these are
leaders who know their communities well
who are better placed to be able to
drive economic growth and build thriving
local economies and instead what we've
got is the Absurd situation where
they're going cap in hands to
Westminster and Whitehall asking for
small powers and resources in order to
do the things they know that works today
we've released the dossier that shows
that this government is over
micromanaging to such an extent that
they're even telling local authorities
when and how to remove chewing gum from
park benches we think this country can
do far far better than that and that's
why we say that we're going to get the
economy growing in every part of Britain
so that young people in every Community
know that they can have the choices and
chances that they deserve
thank you very much indeed Lisa and Andy
there